[Music]
forgive me ma'am but very few company
ladies travel beyond Oman and they are
missing some rare beauty you're not a
soldier's wife no I'm a painter affair
yes no no none of me to be presumptuous
but you did that certain look what look
is that
look at someone filled with no
intentions western Missouri can be
lethal she came all the way from New
York to paint India I'm going to paint
the Great Sioux chief Sitting Bull that
a fact
I've traveled many miles from the east
across many rivers and Hills for the
honor of speaking with you you got a
train from New York right yes
nice you're not good at keeping still
are you shoot me then I will be still
what would be the point of shooting you
bullets don't seem to have any effect
this was my vision my soldiers thought
in the sky Custer with his army they
tracked down every chief tells them all
except for you the only battle ever
fought against his insignificant Olivia
do not give him reason out no one hears
forgot never forgiven least about the
7th Calvary said over now sitting both
dead you'll think that you and me up
letting some kind of uprising the people
need a sign for them to believe in their
own strength
they've been angry for a long time I
fear that is returned to decode is about
revenge
you idiots and Washington want to start
another war if we fight don't mess
across all this what the general wanted
all along
and be banned that's what the bull wants
to know terrible things have happened
here in the past I'm just here to paint
the painting
[Music]
you